wow we got so much insanity this chapter
including the deadly truth Sabo found
out the secret of the the initial
imusama and the guru says crazy devil
fruits revealed and more Insanity in
this epic game changing chapter so make
sure to stay tuned for that channel
parking with it and smash that like
button if you enjoy seeing these one
piece reviews and want to keep them
coming make this the video you joined
the knock mode by subscribing and
hitting that notification Bell to turn
on all notifications so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates and
now without further Ado let's jump into
this craziest of crazy chapters spoilers
and all so this chapter is called the
death of Cobra and as you'd imagine it
will explain the actual death and how
Sabo got caught up in it the narrator
says the impossible ruler as Cobra is
seen looking at the empty Throne being
not so empty he thinks to himself that
no one is ever supposed to sit there no
individual should have the power to
control the world imusama says moo
referring to themselves in the third
person shall address two of the points
being discussed and thou must answer a
single question in turn moo Naruto fans
will recognize as being associated with
a void or nothingness in Naruto mu and
underrated tsuchikage was renowned as
the non-person due to his ability which
left neither a physical form or
detectable chakra signature similarly
emu has been able to go so long as a
non-person so to speak with people not
even knowing they exist so it seems like
a very fitting name Cobra asks emu who
are you as you can imagine he's in the
worst position right now he's in a room
alone with the five elders and a person
who shouldn't even exist it isn't
looking good for him at all but at least
he can try to get some answers before
they take him down Cobra says he's heard
the name emu before he says it could be
a coincidence but one of the first 20
was also called that but I think we all
know it ain't a coincidence so even if
it's not Lily like many thought but
another one of the first 20 it would
still mean that imusama is hella old and
probably Immortal as we thought imusama
comments that such curiosity Teeters on
impertinence it will not be dignified
with an answer we're told however
fortunately imusama says those initial
questions will be addressed D is the
moniker we're told of their ancient
enemy in recent times it has cropped up
more frequently but it is nothing but a
faint Echo interesting comment
especially that faint echo part emu goes
on to say those who carry the name do
not even know of its true meaning now
and yet this irritation only endures due
to Queen Lily's grave blunder 800 years
ago so now it definitely doesn't look
like Queen Lily which makes sense
because if she's related to COBRA and
Vivi she probably wouldn't be evil emu
says the same can be said of those
irksome Scholars investigating the
so-called void Century without that
blunder there would be no Pirates
chasing the poneglyphs in pursuit of
treasure either if it were not for
Lily's incompetence those vexing relics
would never have been scattered all over
the world the release of the poneoglyphs
was the worst possible outcome for us
emu continues so one must wonder whether
it was truly a mistake or if it was
actually part of some larger plan and it
definitely sounds like it was planned if
you ask me the fact that it was framed
as an accident is probably the only
reason Cobra and Vivi have even made it
this far so then the Goro say proceed to
reach for their weapons guns or sword
imusama says the truth undoubtedly lies
in the letter Lily left so pray tell was
it a deliberate choice to only refer to
her as Queen Lily of house nefertari go
on and divulge the full name on her
letter as written Cobra realizes at this
point that he's done he has no chance of
leaving the room alive he says there is
no FIB he could tell that would satisfy
them enough to let him go the Goro say
straight up point out that his fate was
decided the moment he saw the great emu
and Cobra thinks to himself that yeah
they can't let anyone know that the
world's greatest taboo has been broken
and then we see the crazy fact that Sabo
is there listening in on the
conversation he hears what the truth is
the truth is that the letter from
alabaster's ruler eight centuries ago
was signed by Queen nefertari D Lily and
then immediately emu seems to go in for
the attack the attack consists of a
Black Arrow but honestly it looks like
it could be a devil's tale too I'll
leave most of the speculation for the
comment section let me know what you
think it is a logia of some sort or as
seems most likely these days of fruit
from the most hyped category of mythical
Zone some speculate that Blackbeard
could have the devil devil fruit but it
could also be that emu has it especially
when we pay attention to what Sabo is
going to say later anyways The Black
Arrow moving things stabs through Cobra
then Sabo takes action so a bit late but
I assume that the arrow thing is
insanely fast and he acted as soon as he
could it was even sudden with the
paneling that Oda used Sabo then uses
fire fist smothered mate which is a
chess and shogi reference and as a chess
fan I appreciate that Oda keep them
coming the attack engulfs the girl will
say and leads up to EMU emu is upset
saying where did this one come from but
then it's revealed that yes the Goro say
aren't just for show they do have powers
and are Fighters they not only survive
the fire attack we see more shadowy
Silhouettes that must point to their
devil fruit powers or perhaps they were
given these abilities by imusama's
awakened devil fruit either way this
definitely makes the Government powers
look a lot stronger it's a complete 180
from Recently not only do we now have
the Holy nights in addition to the
Admirals but also go to say and final
boss emu crazy stuff straw hats and
revolutionaries will definitely have to
team up now Sabo said he was hoping he'd
be able to take them out in one move but
in all honesty that would have been so
anticlimactic so it makes sense that he
couldn't and then Sabo says after all
there's no way I could have known that
hell was located here at the very top of
the world so a comment like that again
lends to imusama potentially having an
awakened devil devil fruit and and
perhaps the goros say look like hellish
underlings right now looking forward to
seeing more than just Silhouettes and
finding out if perhaps they all have
mythical zones of their own or if these
are powers granted by imusama Cobra and
Sabo share a quick exchange where Sabo
explains that he a revolutionary is
saving Cobra because they are more
concerned with the monsters above the
kings and queens and then they talk
about Luffy Cobra says he saved him too
and Sabo says haha that sounds like him
then we get this pretty epic panel that
definitely looks like Sabo is trying to
escape hell while the largeness of the
creatures dominate the frame I mean it's
just impressive that he managed to
escape eventually and it definitely
makes sense why they would try to erase
an island to get to him now after we
know what he knew Cobra wants Sabo to
leave him so he can escape without the
dead weight Sabo at first completely
refuses being the stand-up guy he is
it's just funny how the news articles
could not get it any anymore wrong when
they framed Sabo for being the one that
killed Cobra even though he tried so
hard to save him Cobra then tells Sabo
that he and Vivi share the moniker D and
he finally knows the path alabasta must
follow Sabo then gets a flashback of
discussing Luffy and Ace both having the
D in their names and wondering if it's a
coincidence or something they even joked
that he could be sa di Beau which is
pretty hilarious back to the present and
again The Black Arrow stabs through Sabo
and Cobra Sabo is clearly in a lot of
pain so he didn't purposely drop Cobra
but he did drop him as a result of the
attack then one of the transformed girls
they approached Cobra Cobra quotes
nefertari D Lilly saying the pawnoglyphs
dot dot dot fly the flag that Heralds
the world's eventual Dawn end quote
unfortunately exactly what was said is
purposely covered with a scream in the
manga Cobra prepares to hold the gorosei
back from Sabo with his life and says
that he's counting on Sabo Sabo screams
King Cobra's name while Kobe thinks that
Sabo must live on then we see that of
all people King waffle has noticed what
happened through a hole in the wall in
witnessing this truth is the worst that
could happen and Walpole knows it he
says that himself as he runs he stumbled
upon the biggest skeleton in the
government's closet he doesn't even want
to know who that was they will end him
he cries we then hear that Cobra and
Waffle won't make it to the meeting and
see shirahoshi wanting to say bye to
Vivi however Vivi is tied up she asks
whose orders are cp0 following they just
say that no one's going to help her and
that once her disappearance is made
known she'll probably live the rest of
her life like a pet Vivi wonders if
shirahoshi is all right although she's
at first told that she should worry
about herself she is also told that
shirahoshi came out of her ordeal on
scave and Vivi says thank goodness
showing what a stand-up lady she is it's
funny seeing how the members of the
straw hat Grand Fleet proclaimed their
Victory and gave their names to the
shock of the guests in the courtyard not
a good look for the gov government when
they can just do that it looks so
awesome doing it by the way and then we
even hear that fujitora's actions help
the Revolutionary Army free the slaves
and that obviously made Greenville angry
so they went at it so this bit of
infighting also helps explain why the
revolutionaries did so well if you ask
me fujitora is low-key a straw hat Grand
fleet member even if he doesn't know it
yet Vivi starts wondering what to do and
props to her for being strategic and not
just giving up and then just when things
look hopeless the Savior appears the
legend Walpole himself shows up eating
through the walls and Vivi sees her
chance wapul says stay out of the way
but viviu purposely gets in the way and
gets carried with waffle she asks how
much farther is he gonna go and he says
as far as it takes to the ends of the
world if he has to and she says sounds
good to me let's go which definitely
makes sense from her perspective and
then we get the perfect ending to the
chapter it's commented that waffle is
running away with a mistress and the
narrator even gets in on it saying there
loping to start a new life on the run a
hilarious ending to a very huge chapter
and the pacing was great the chapter is
over and we're still moving fast right
up to the last panel everything was
either an insane information drop this
chapter or action-packed now that the
government is looking so strong you
won't want to miss my breakdown of all
the yonko that will have to clash with
them soon and their powers link on
screen to that Yoko video right now and
I'll see you there